all right the news continues pouring in
things have
simmered down a little bit from the ins
uh insurrectionist riotous coup attempt
by trump supporters that took place
on wednesday but a lot of crazy is
really going on i told you yesterday
that facebook and twitter had
temporarily suspended donald trump for
posting election dissing for
disinformation and incitements to
violence
we have now heard from mark zuckerberg
facebook will be blocking donald trump
on
all its platforms which includes
instagram at least until the end of his
presidency uh
mark zuckerberg made a post about this
uh
yesterday and you know i i don't really
care about zuckerberg in the term
in terms of evaluating his morality and
his personal politics i know that
there's reason to be very upset as to
how facebook has sort of looked the
other way with a lot of the
completely ridiculous ways that the
trump campaign and the right have used
facebook to spread disinformation and so
on
uh this statement from mark zuckerberg
is what it is
and zuckerberg wrote the shocking events
of the last 24 hours
clearly demonstrate that president
donald trump intends to use his
remaining time in office to
undermine the peaceful and lawful
transition of power
to his elected successor joe biden
and he goes on to say we believe the
risks of allowing the president to
continue to use our service during this
period are simply too great
therefore we are extending the block we
have placed on his facebook
and instagram accounts indefinitely and
for at least
the next two weeks until the peaceful
transition of power is complete so
a an indefinite ban on facebook and
instagram for donald trump and it's all
just
you know the the struggle with these um
incidents is that on the one hand
all of this stuff should have happened
long ago trump's cabinet should have
considered the 25th amendment long ago
trump's cabinet should have resigned
long ago republicans should have
abandoned trump long ago
pence should have distanced from trump
long ago on
twitter and facebook all this stuff but
at this late stage
it's sort of like come on guys uh
it almost feels like a virtue signal in
some sense to me
uh in order to try to rehabilitate
one's image and one could be a person or
a company
when it's too little too late when trump
is now already weakened
and humiliated with just you know 12
days left until the inauguration
so while these are obviously the correct
decisions
it's hard to really feel like wow it's
so great everybody's now
figuring it out we figured it out before
trump was even inaugurated and some of
us were called alarmists and of course
every one of our worst fears
uh came true so we'll continue to follow
this
uh i believe it's quite plausible trump
will be permanently banned uh
from um uh twitter as well
uh after he leaves office
but um it is it's really anyone's guess
at this point and one of the things i
think it's it's important to remember i
mentioned this yesterday
let's not allow the uh retroactive
rehabilitation of the image of a lot of
these people that were along for the
ride 99.9 percent of trump's term
and now are bailing absolutely
massive conflict within trump's
cabinet on wednesday as the
violent insurrection was breaching the
capital
donald trump denounced mike pence and
said pence didn't do it
pence didn't do it he didn't steal the
election for for me
and um that tweet was ultimately taken
down by twitter
and it was one of the tweets that led to
donald trump's suspension on twitter
regardless of your workout nutrition and
diet goals
it is crucial to have the right amount
of protein
in your diet and if you're supplementing
with protein powders you should be sure
you have the powder that is right for
you
and that's where our sponsor gainful
comes in gainful offers customized
protein
based on your body type diet fitness
habits
and goals their formulas are optimized
for you
with simple and effective ingredients no
fillers gluten soy
or anything artificial and gainful also
gives you free
unlimited one-on-one access to your own
registered dietitian
which is a great bonus you won't find
anywhere else and my favorite part is
that gainful protein
is never repetitive or boring because
they will rotate the flavors you choose
like rich chocolate cookies and cream
chocolate peanut butter strawberry cream
cafe mocha
i took their quiz and they gave me
protein tailored to my
specific needs everything was quick and
easy i've been loving what they sent me
you'll get 15 off your first month
when you go to gainful.com pacman the
link is underneath this video